[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening Europe
welcome to your vision debate there is
just over a week to go before you up
goes to support in the European
Parliament elections so tonight we put
the big questions to the people who want
to lead so you go PN Commission for the
next five years we are live from the
European Parliament in Brussels where
six candidates for the position of
President of the European Commission
will make their pitch for Europe's top
top real life across Europe on embers of
Eurovision but we are also being watched
around the world online you're all very
welcome
so we are your hosts I am a media news
anchor from French TV imacros price EU
correspondent with ard German TV and I
am honest Tina heckler I work as a
correspondent for the finished
television in Paris and I will be
guiding you through the debate on social
media but it's not about us it's about
the candidates for Europe's top job so
please welcome
Nico QA a Spanish ball Belgian trade
unionists a lead candidate for the
European left
[Applause]
from Germany scheduler for the European
Green Party it's her second Eurovision
debates from the Czech Republic
the Yanks our deal member of the
European Parliament for alliance of
conservatives and we from it in Europe
acting EU competition commissioner
market divestiture for the Alliance of
liberals and Democrats for Europe from
Germany monthly Weber chairman of the
European People's Party in the European
Parliament and Spitz in Canada and
finally from the Netherlands France
Timmerman's first vice-president of the
European Commission the candidate of the
party of European socialists
this debate is nothing without you all
over Europe and that's where Ernestina
comes in yes I will be your social media
host this evening so you are a crucial
part of this debate throughout the
program I will be monitoring the
millions of Europeans who are following
us online asking questions reacting and
engaging with us in the digital world so
tell us what matters to you by using the
hashtag tell Europe and make your voice
heard of course every debate has rules
and this one is no different so this
debate will last 90 minutes each
candidate will have one minute to answer
each question and during the debates
they will have each two opportunities to
challenge other candidates and we really
encourage all of you to make use of this
rebuttal card because then we have
really a lively debate here on stage
each participant will also have the
opportunity to make opening and closing
statements speaking order was decided in
a draw and let's begin Nico Correa the
the floor is yours
good evening my name is Nico Kui I am a
candidate for the European Left Party
I was born in Asturias in the north of
Spain when my father was a minor that he
was forced to leave Spain because he was
opposed to the Franco regime the
dictatorship
we were welcomed in Belgium by people
who showed a lot of solidarity towards
us we were able to build a home work
study and it's this solidarity that
really gave me the desire to work with
Europe it's a Europe of solidarity that
I've always fought for it as a trade
union representative and that is the
Europe that I want to continue to defend
but unfortunately this is also the
Europe of tax evasion the Europe of the
banks the Europe that has failed to show
solidarity so I would like to create a
Europe of solidarity hello everyone this
debate and these elections are important
because people from all over Europe are
looking at us and they're asking for
solutions they know many things are
going wrong from the climate crisis
to austerity to the backlash against
democracy and civil liberties Europe is
struggling to fulfill the promises that
has been built on and tonight I want to
make the case for a different Europe one
that protects our common planet the only
one that we have as social Europe where
everyone finds decent housing and has a
decent wage we as greens take the battle
for European Union where the big
companies pay their fair share where
women are truly treated equal where
minorities are respected human rights
are protected I know it is possible to
build this different Europe if we build
together and if we build it with courage
thank you very much Scott Keller and
next in line is yawns already good
evening everyone I believe that we
cannot meet all those new challenges of
21st century with old and outdated
scheme of every closer Union which has
been designed 50 years ago for a
different age therefore I would propose
rather you which is scaled back which is
flexible which is decentralized I would
like to have European Commission which
respects all its members regardless
whether they are big or small or whether
they are from the West or from the east
I would like to have Europe
Commission which respects national
governments and which cooperates with
them which doesn't fight them which
doesn't patronize them which doesn't
lecture them simply speaking I would
like to have European Union which is
doing less but better and which is able
to find new equilibrium between national
and European level and this is the
European Union and this is the change I
am ready and able to deliver thank you
yes they're ideal migrate West I go it's
it on I am a guy to be stea I'm from
Denmark my husband and I have three
daughters I was a minister a political
leader today I work for you as
commissioner of competition I make sure
that businesses play by the rulebook
so you as a consumer have choice quality
and fair prices for me the most
important thing is that you are
empowered to live the life you want to
live in your community that you feel
counted in you have a fair chance of
making it Europe is the best place to
live today especially if you're a woman
we have achieved so much that doesn't
make everything good we have work to do
to fight climate change to deal with
technology to create societies built on
the rule of law where you can provide
for yourself to make that everyday life
that's why I'm here thank you very much
Margaret of s.tiger and we take it to
monthly favor please
I want to thank you I had the
opportunity in the last weeks and months
during my electoral campaign to travel a
lot around the European Union and to
meet a lot of Europeans the experience
that we have the same concerns even the
same fears and the same hopes for the
future of our continent and what I want
to tell you what this is method how I
want to work on Commission level on
European level a Europe which is close
to people a [ __ ] cares about the
concrete issues from the citizens a
commission of the people that is what I
want to work for and having this in mind
I think jean-claude Juncker the current
Commission president
called and named his commission the
commission of the last chance and he
he's on you PP Commission president I
think he did a good job I want to call
the next Commission not the commission
of the last chance I want to call it the
commission of a fresh start of a new era
of readiness openness for optimism for
showing to the world that we can achieve
is European so much together thank you
thank you my friend Weber finally France
tournaments thank you good evening you
know you have the future of Europe in
the palm of your hands next week you
will decide the fate of Europe in the
next five years there are those who say
that Europe and this its citizens are
best served by breaking down the
European Union I don't believe in that
now those who say to avoid breaking down
the European Union we have to maintain
it as it is I don't believe that either
I believe to safe and strengthen Europe
we need to fundamentally reform Europe
it's time big companies finally started
paying taxes it's time we introduced the
minimum wage in every member state it is
time we have equality in pay of men and
women it is time we put an end to
violence against women in Europe it is
time we enforce the rule of law in every
member state so that everybody about
abides by the rules it is time we put
the climate crisis and sustainability on
the very very top of the list of the
next commission that is my proposal to
you tonight Thank You France in my mind
since you - all for your introduction
but you know it should abate to you in
front of your screens so let me join
anise Tina now online for all social
media lost anise Tina maybe there is
already some reaction some tweets for
joing we can instigate yes Emily welcome
to the social media hub as you see we
are here following all your comments and
questions with my team and yes the
conversation it has already started it
has been very lively questions have
actually been pouring in already before
the debate
and hashtag tell Europe it is already
trending in Belgium and in Germany and
as you can imagine there are some topics
that are already very popular online any
idea what they are well let me tell you
bricks it climate change digital privacy
and migration in fact Seawatch have
tweeted using hashtag tell Europe that
they rescued 65 people from the
Mediterranean today so clearly this is a
major issue so make your voice heard
keep your comments coming and questions
coming and use the hashtag tell Europe
let's get back to the main stage and get
started with the debate thank you very
much Ernestina for this first glimpse
into the social media landscape and we
are also starting on migration this has
been the topic most mentioned by many
Europeans when surveyed about their
concerns but Europe has failed to find a
common political solution for the
problem the ideas of resettlement are
met with opposition and even for a few
dozens of migrants arriving on ships
like the Seawatch or on their carriers
we see our governments fighting who is
going to take them so our question to
you is given the fractures of the
tensions we see about migrations would
you as a commission president drop the
efforts to find a common solution and if
not how do you solve the problem the
question goes to mr. zahary please thank
you first of all I have to say that I
would never repeat the same mistake like
the current Commission by introducing
mandatory quota which unfortunately
didn't work and which unfortunately only
deepened the divide between Eastern part
and western part of Europe I believe
that we should find another solutions we
should respect the sovereign right of
governments and Parliament's in Member
States to grant or not to grant asylum
to grant or not to grant temporary or
permanent settlement or even citizenship
what we have to do is however to fight
human trafficking and human smuggling
what we have to do is to outsource
reception centers to outside of the
European Union otherwise we won't be
able to fight trafficking and smuggling
we of course have to somehow conduct
readmission agreements with other
countries and that they will be willing
so we have to cooperate closely and
first of all we have to help stabilize
situation in Africa thank you thank you
mrs. our they'll match fit paper what
would you do
the only chance is a European solution
no doubt about this and there are two
main pillars for us is EPP one pillar is
that the state controls who is arriving
in Europe and not the smugglers that we
have to win back the control on our
border and that must be clear that's why
we ask for 10,000 Frontex offices
immediately established to control the
ball as a second element is when Pope
Francis is in front of the lamp of the
military and see in Lampedusa and is
reminding us on our humanitarian
responsibility we have to take over this
responsibility we have to care that
means resettlement for Syria that means
a big martial plan for Africa I want to
establish a commissioner only dealing
with African interests to make also from
structure of the Commission clear that
we prioritize on these things and there
are the two sides of the metal strict
border control and humanitarian
responsibility and my party did it so
Angela Merkel the Chancellor of Germany
Germany we showed that we take over
responsibility and Angela Merkel
together together with jean-claude
Juncker showed also that we are ready to
have a turkey agreement where we win
back the control on our border so both
elements are crucial thank you very much
Manfred Weber mr. krei would you drop
the efforts let me recall that
immigration is first and foremost a
human drama and I'm actually the son of
an illegal immigrant
my parents arrived here without any
documents and more than 30,000 people
have been killed in the Mediterranean 50
people were killed just yesterday in the
Mediterranean
when a boat capsized and I think the
European Union has a great
responsibility here and all of the
policies that have led to
destabilization need to be revised for
the European left
we believe that migration is an
opportunity I'm an example of that this
is an opportunity for a series of people
who don't have the opportunity back home
in their countries to flourish for us
we're not in we don't believe that it's
about the invasion of Europe we're
talking about 0.5% of the population and
these people can contribute to
rejuvenating Europe I am the son of a
migrant and I think the statement of mr.
Weber where he talked about a final
solution for immigration is scandalous
Thank You mr. girl what would you do
with my ones I'm having on ships exact
queries for example well I think the
important thing is to treat sort of the
long-term stable solution with the same
urgency a saving life at sea because
otherwise we will never get to a
solution because migration is here to
stay because of climate change because
of changes in economic conditions but
the most important thing is that I see
Europeans having an open big heart for
Refugees to protect people in need of
protection and at the same time to
expect us to find ways to manage
migration and to make it legal because
we cannot have people coming and going
without knowing and in that of course we
need exactly common solutions we need a
common Asylum system and we need a
common solidarity and we can discuss how
to make that happen but we need to do
that together because otherwise we'd
fail Thank You Magnus tiger so we heard
a lot about what about what we should do
France timmermans as acting first
vice-president of the Commission saw
what is difficult to do what could be
done better under your watch as
president of the European Commission I
think first of all every time a person
dies in the Mediterranean Europe loses a
bit of its soul
so we're losing who we are we're losing
our values by not solving this problem
secondly once people are on boats in the
Mediterranean you have to take care of
these people
and you shouldn't put fines on fishermen
or other people in other boats who
rescue people at sea like the Italian
government is doing now that is
unacceptable thirdly you have to prevent
people from getting on those boats in
the first place and for that you really
need I agree with Manfred Weber a huge
plan for Africa you need to understand
that Europe's destiny is linked to
Africa's destiny but only with these
measures and better Border Protection
and agreements with third countries we
will not solve it we also need
solidarity in Europe solidarity is not
just for things you like it's also
sometimes for things you don't like and
if central Eastern European countries
continue to refuse solidarity sooner or
later borders will be back in Europe
where they don't belong and that would
be to the detriment of every citizen in
Europe we need to prevent that we need
solidarity gives a clear perspective
thank you thank you thank you France
women Commission what would you do we
stand clearly for a European solidarity
we need to fairly share the
responsibility that we need to face we
also need to support the communities
that are actually doing so much already
to welcome people and need many cities
many people many initiatives are helping
but really what is absolutely
unacceptable is what's happening right
now in the Mediterranean people are
drowning and we know where they are they
are calling the search and rescue center
no one is picking up the phone the
Italians are telling them to call the
Libyans in Libya no one is answering the
phone there is a civil war in Libya
there is no Coast Guard and were even
giving to those militias which call
themselves Coast Guard's support this
should not happen we need to have a
European search-and-rescue effort
because we should not allow that any
single person dies in the Mediterranean
thank you
Thank You specular thanks for the first
one of francerz house second question
isn't use unemployment if you look into
the details you see there was a huge gap
between countries in the north and east
and those like Greece Portugal Italy or
even friends you stand on youth
unemployment in Greece for instance is
at 39% but what is the explanation for
that too much austerity like in Greece
or Portugal or maybe not enough reforms
like perhaps in France or in Italy a
question to the candidate how would you
try to bring the Moors and 3.3 million
young Europeans back into jobs mr. sir
ideal so far is yours
well first of all let's be very clear
that this is not the European Commission
which creates jobs businesses create
jobs and European Commission can create
business friendly environment by good
legislation and by funding good programs
from its budget and some good programs
have been already developed we have for
instance digital Europe funded by I
think 10 billion of euros we have also
horizon Europe which is supporting
research and development with another
part of the European budget and we have
also invest you which combines private
and public resources for improving
infrastructure so what I believe is that
we need some tailor-made solutions for
each and every country because our
economies are very diverse structures of
our national economies are different and
if you look at Europe you can see that
in some countries is actually
unemployment very low in my own country
is less than 3% so tailor-made solutions
encouragement of new programs and good
legislation these are my solutions thank
you and Zara do we take it to month with
Weber Germany also in this always
insists on austerity on the 3% criteria
is this also a course for the youth
unemployment in the South we're seeing
and are you gonna change something about
it
well I remind the chairman's they touch
the Austrians to finish who were doing
quite well at the moment economically
that they only can have a good future if
we can create jobs and growth especially
for the young generation in the south we
only can added the challenges together
so it's responsibility and solidarity
together we have to bring these things
in one line
and I want to describe one element that
was in Portugal in Porto I met with
young students there and they told me
that France they were not first of all
asking about minimum wages because that
is one of the proposals from the
Socialists they were asking the young
generation that house is asking for
chops for good paid jobs for good
salaries to establish their own families
and that's why we need a good economic
policy to create to create these jobs
and that is infrastructure that is
research there is openness for trade and
there is for all of us to practice a
strong single market to establish even a
stronger single market for the future so
social is what is creating shops just
[Applause]
remember you have to we work out to
challenge other candidates so Nico Kui
do you agree with Manfred Weber economy
a good economy policies a solution to
get unemployment down in Europe imagine
possible no I don't think so because
they're in power now and they've been in
power for a long time but the policies
are completely not up to the job with
emu the euro more austerity labor law
reforms precarious work at wages and
salaries which often are below the
minimum wage and at the same time
increasing the pensionable ages which
means that the older people are working
until 65 and young people are sitting at
home out of a job we have to put an end
to precarious work and get back to
proper labour contracts which have got
prospects not just 0s comp contracts
which don't give young people any kind
of future at a European military a
European minimum wage which is worth
getting up for in the morning that's
what young people want and this proper
labor contracts should be on offer to
young people across Europe thank you
[Applause]
just like the general business
environment we can do something about
but not really giving an answer to
millions of young Europeans who want a
job well I think we can do both because
European countries have come together to
make sure that in every country there is
an offer of education or training or a
specific job because with with no job
you just open the door to no future and
of course it's very good points that we
need a strong economy we need to invest
we need to make sure that businesses can
do business and grow and we see jobs are
being created in Europe I think more
than 12 million jobs over the last five
years but a lot of those jobs they don't
pay very well and we should agree that
we should promote an economy where you
can make a decent living when you have a
full-time job and that may be another
discussion than having a sort of fixed
minimum wage because we have different
systems and that I think is important to
respect that because we need to call on
the social partners to help us out
because the European Union as such can
do something but together with
member-states then we can solve it thank
you sir France tournaments you can
answer the vice president of European
Commission now as a future president of
four European Commission but first of
all I'm when I'm in Portugal young
people in Portugal asked me when Antonio
Costa came with plans to create more
social justice to get more jobs to
create more economic growth and the
European Commission said go ahead
Manfred Weber said no punish Portugal
punish Portugal so that's the question I
got but coming back to the question on
the young people first of all very
concretely let's expand Erasmus to every
young person in Europe regardless of
whether they are in school or in
university or in high school whether
they have a job or not a job it gives
them an experience to learn from other
member states secondly make sure there
is a minimum wage that is on average 60
percent of median wage that will protect
young people against these jobs where
they get two or three euros an hour
thirdly youth guarantee plan expand the
youth guarantee plan that's been very
successful in quite a number of member
states we should expand that and more
than that lower the voting age to 16
years so that young people have bigger
say in the decisions we take it national
European level I already thought they
agree on everything apparently but know
that we saw the first rebuttal card from
monthly paper so 30 seconds for you and
then 30 seconds an answer from France
the moment so we all share that
solidarity is a key issue for Europe but
again responsibility and not
responsibility I have to remind everyone
that in the last five years it was
Commissioner Moscovici social is
responsible for the programming on the
euro question it was titled Blum a
former colleague of France timmermans as
Minister from Netherlands was chairing
the Eco fiends of the Euro group which
did the necessary decisions on reforming
and today it's a socialist finance
minister from Portugal who is chairing
this ECOFIN group the responsible body
the Euro group the responsible body who
is doing the necessary steps so I think
everybody should take over
responsibility the socialist policies
this had nothing to do with what I said
get Moscow VC looked at the plans and
said they're okay
jean-claude juncker looked at the plans
of Portugal and said okay this can work
and the manfred raver said from the
European Parliament no we will not allow
this you should punish Portugal they
shouldn't do this and this is what
happened it worked
social justice is bigger in Portugal
jobs have increased enormously in
Portugal because they put an end to
austerity and that is what more
governments should be doing thank you
very much Supermax and last in line on
that is schedule a please I think there
are 30 measures that have been taken in
Europe have really done a big damage it
has done a damage to people personally
people were deprived of their jobs I
mean it's young people very much but
it's not just young people but it also
also really given a blow to that
European promise of that we would be
jointly creating prosperity so I think
it was a big mistake for every sort of
mission we shouldn't forget if a young
person is unemployed that would mean
that young person will have a lower
income in the future as well so tackling
youth unemployment is crucial and it's
an issue for the whole of the European
Union
not just from single member states or
regions so we should make the youth
guarantee binding everywhere and it
needs to be fully financed and we need
to make sure that we have the right jobs
in the future investing in the greeny
common economy even the Commission has
said it will create hundreds of
thousands of jobs so why do we wait with
that why not start with making sure that
investments we do are exactly targeted
towards the social and ecological
transition of our economy thank you
Karen
yes already I want to say you something
if I may
how would you would you agree that there
is a very diverse level of unemployment
at individual member countries you have
over ten percent in some countries and
we have less than three percent in some
other countries would you agree that
this is a very good evidence a very good
example
in fact national governments and
national parliaments are better able to
create tailor-made solutions for their
own labor market than the European
Commission can do well with me that if
we had applied the same reasoning on
structural funds for new member states
15 years ago the Czech Republic would
not be as prosperous today the
unemployment in the Czech Republic would
not be as low as it is today so without
structural Fonz's what have happened
they were exactly exactly and this was
an expression of European solidarity
would you not agree with me that it's
also an expression of European
solidarity not just to say we have low
unemployment figures but we care about
the fact that in southern Europe more
than 30 percent of the young people are
unemployed and we will help solve the
photo thank thank you very much
cinnamons and I hope you understand why
I encourage you to use your rebuttal
cards so we are getting kind of a debate
now thank you all thank you Scott Keller
thank you all for your first answers on
migration and on youth unemployment old
fashioned here on the stage but let's
have a look at the fancies social media
stage yes it has been great to see that
thousands of you are are already getting
involved the hashtag tell Europe has
been mentioned more than 7,000 times and
let's see how far that goes by the end
of the night I really hope to see the
Finns
here too because you know last night we
didn't do that well in their semi-finals
of the Eurovision Song Contest so make
your voice be heard tonight and all your
other Europeans of course - and speaking
of engagement many of you sent us your
reasons for going to vote at the
upcoming elections in a European
Parliament poll you told us that you are
voting to fight climate change change
Europe for the better to stop so-called
toxic nationalism and to t keep
democracy going so how is the online
community responding to our first topics
let's have a let's have a look
migration it has definitely provoked
very heated discussion this user from
Belgium would like to see EU citizens
allowed to support migrants with shelter
and food and I can also tell you that
there is huge interest in climate change
many of you have sent in all kinds of
questions on this subject from Germany
we have a direct question asking
candidates what they will do to fight
climate change and to prevent crisis
we'd like to hear more from the
candidates so let's get back to the
debate thank you Anna staff was a
perfect transition because we can move
on on the next topic Environment and
climate change
they are your Ceasar thousands of
Europeans young Europeans out on the
streets with with a sandbank with the
Fridays for future movements every other
week we get a new scientific we brought
Eugene politicians like you to act you
to act but still effective climate
protection could prove very expensive
jobs in the coal or car industry could
be lost
energy costs ordinary people more money
so our question to the candidate is do
you think we have to make sacrifices in
order to protect the planet our planet
what would you do more or while what
would you do less please name name
concrete proposal market-based I go well
of course it's the risk but I think we
can make the most of it by looking at it
as an opportunity because millions of
jobs can be created for instance
building high-speed rails in Europe -
connects our cities to make sure that
people can get around out of the plains
down to the trains that is very specific
that can work and second a lot of things
is now prepared we have set targets we
have the legislation to reform our
markets now we can go do
a lot of the technology we need we have
it already so we can invest European
funds and national funds and of course
we can research even more than we do
today
but we don't need to wait for technology
we have so many things to do already and
the greatest thing is that while we do
something systemically each and every
one of us can take part by our not our
personal choices but we can never just
decentralize it - each and every citizen
because this is something that we'll
have to do together thank you very much
my great the best tiger Skye Cara I
assume you take the climate goals very
serious but other greens also ready to
accept job losses to achieve we take
this issue very serious and I think we
all should because this is a serious
urgency we only have one single planet
and we need to protect it we cannot do
it compromise and say to the climate you
know just wait a bit we're still not
sure what to do no we can't do that but
the good thing is that we know what to
do the policy instruments the measures
that we need to take we know them we
have them on the table we just need to
do them and that has been a problem that
unfortunately other groups present here
have constantly voted against our
progress in fighting that climate crisis
and it really is crisis especially if we
combine it with the loss of biodiversity
so this is really a hot and very
important issue that we have to address
what I would do is for example stopping
the climate harmful subsidies that we're
spending every year the European Union
level there's billions of euros that we
should stop putting into the wrong use
and put it into good use for example in
climate friendly technology which for
example also creates a lot of jobs all
the new jobs that would be would be
created in a climate friendly technology
and economy that would be here to stay
right now we're letting them go to China
thank you thank you
France timmermans have a vice president
of European Commission do you heard the
young European into the street do you
heard zero we thought of the scientific
yep it's what I hear everywhere I go
every day ten times a day every day
first of all let me say
Skye said Skye Keller set some clear
words about this mr. kuai is one of the
leading leading politicians in the
European Parliament's on climate change
and on the environment the three of us
already have quite good record in the
last five years in the European
Parliament my offer to them is let's
work together in the next five years so
that we make sure the next Commission
puts the climate prices on the top of
its agenda and I'm sure we will also
convince many many people in the liberal
family so that we create in alliance
going from C plus all the way to my call
to make sure we put this on the highest
level of our agenda but concretely why
are we not taxing kerosene we're taxing
the the fuel in the cars and then the
trains but on the airplanes unacceptable
why are we not introducing a co2 tax for
all companies in Europe a co2 tax which
revenues we can then bring back to the
people so that they can make their
housing sustainable for instance so why
are we not introducing these measures we
can do that we can do that if we agree
with the Member States and if we enforce
this also with the help of the European
Parliament thank you very much
France the moments and I think we saw
the first stage of coalition building
here but I assume we go to the
opposition now Yan's are ideal what
would you do more on climate protection
or perhaps less look I came from that
part of Europe centuries in Europe which
30 years ago was one of the most
polluted parts not only of Europe of the
world now we over those 30 years we have
reduced the air pollution for hundreds
of percents so it is achievable but it
has to be done in a socially sustainable
way and gradually while introducing new
technologies and that's what I'm calling
for socially sustainable way and gradual
phasing right sign table so let's not
put unrealistic targets ahead of us
let's commit those commitments let's
fulfill those commitments we have signed
for instance the Paris climate agreement
rather come to when it comes to the
Commission Commission could and should
change the way how for instance our
subsidies from a common agriculture
policy paid they should be more
environmentally oriented more subsidized
organic farming
all farming and not only production
oriented and there is one more actually
a good program which was already devised
by the Commission and I have to praise
the Commission for that it's called one
hectare and this I will add later we are
sorry for that yes thanks thanks for
examle cook cooing hunger seed oh well
I'd like to thank the young people who
for the many weeks now have been going
out on the streets because they get the
impression that they are not being
listened to and it's true they haven't
been listened to we hear lots of fine
words from European politicians but
there haven't been any concrete measures
taken we are not attacking the big
polluters the multinationals who were
responsible for more than 70% of
pollution of the international level
we're doing nothing there rather with
pushing this on to citizens taxing the
citizens as macron has done in France
that is totally unacceptable
there is an industrial tradition in
Europe Galileo Airbus why can't we go
back to taking a public initiative to
deal with the climate crisis we can't
simply say there's no money we found
three billion to save the banks and mr.
Timmerman tax evasion is at about 800
million and we take it too much big
favor would you be more ambitious on
climate protection than the actual
acting Commission now 50 to achieve a
European Union which is carbon neutral
that is our common goal and that's why I
kind of understand why we create here to
have divisions and we have come an
understanding about what to do for the
future the EPP is clearly committed to
this goal but on the way how we achieve
this there are discussions necessary
because I don't accept that the losers
of the development will be the
pensioners the two people in our
societies will be the industrial workers
of the car industry we have a lot of
concerns about that they can manage this
transitional period
there are a lot of concerns on the table
rural areas again and that's why we have
to make it in a way that everybody can
respect it and when I refer to my EPP
party I tell you it was the Commission
areas Kennedy and EPP Commission who
presented all the initiatives in the
fight against climate change our day
achievements are together with CPP voice
and I will continue just very briefly I
mean we just an NGO went through the
voting in the European Parliament over
the last five years and they call the
EPP dinosaurs so there is a problem
there it's not my word it's what the NGO
did just looking at the voting but
secondly I'm sick and tired of the
excuse it's going to hurt pension it's
going to hurt
socially weak people you know what's
really going to hurt if we do nothing if
we do nothing we'll be in a climate
crisis of incredible proportions if we
do nothing it's support people who will
suffer first they have no way to go
somewhere else to avoid this crisis we
need to act the longer we wait the more
expensive it is and the harder it is and
poor people maneuver again from France
Tim among great words but not concrete
actions you see we need concrete actions
now and that is necessary for achieving
the goal and I tell you the trade
emission system which we established
into the European Union we can expand
this to the aviation sector that would
be an important step or to look for the
question how we can now boost innovation
I believe as an engineer I am an
environmental engineer by my profession
I believe in innovation not in
punishment not in bands not in
regulatory framework I believe in
innovation and that's by establishing an
horizon which is investing in
technologies which are capable to solve
the problems that is what we have to do
we have a lot of further question on
that because we have two more rebuttal
cards first scapulae I do think we have
great differences among the groups among
the parties on the climate issue because
some only talk about the climate and
others like we want to do something
about it very concretely so my very
concrete question to month with Weber is
on that if you're saying emission
trading is great and why did you vote
personally why did your group vote
against reforming the ETS and making it
actually workable right now we're giving
out so many free certificates that they
can go for free and even trade the
certificates among themselves the very
big companies why did you vote against
that why did the EPP vote against more
ambitious climate targets this is not at
all what real climate action looks like
before being we give it a massive wave
up just very briefly ETS wields a
mission trading system for those of you
who are not familiar with that
abbreviation not the paper please
exactly because my party is a party who
trying to bring things together we can
be ambitious and at the top of the
greens in a way to be very strong on
climate change and again I was a meeting
had a meeting with the trade unions not
with CPP voters - trade union socialists
who told me if you implement the goals
of the Greens then we have no future of
for our jobs and that's why let's be
sustainable sustainability from the
United Nation means ecological ambition
also economic stability and also the
question of sustainability in the
technological fields bring things
together and not split because I want to
challenge you and this is because you
sort of insists that my colleague Miguel
is a EPP but he didn't make amazing work
because his EPP he did that because he's
part of the Commission my colleague
Violeta she didn't pave the way to
decarbonize transportation because she's
liberal we work together as a college
and this is not a party congregation
because climate change is so much bigger
than any of us that party affiliation
plays a role and second we have so many
tools already why not just put that
introduced instead of just waiting thank
you but margarita that was exactly my
starting point when I said let's not
create a division on this because of the
goal we are on the same side and frankly
speaking you know that in the liberal
group there are a lot of friends who
share the concerns about the speed of
implementation again 2050 we have to
have a carbon neutral industry and I'm
strongly committed to do
so but not to punish the poor to do it
with innovation with offers to get the
next steps and to be strong on this
thank you very much Matt with paper and
there was still one more challenge from
Nick gray also to you the true Vasa well
I think it's pretty unbearable to hear
this kind of discourse you shut the f---
launch and Liege blast furnace seven or
eight years ago the unionists came up
with all kinds of proposals to create
special steels that didn't need to be
washed and that would have actually
promoted and pushed production levels
for recycling of these materials imagine
the number although the quantity of
detergents that we wouldn't afford down
the drains and produced in Europe but
instead with mr. Tierney you preferred
to plump with mr. metal and allow these
blast furnace to be shut down and
allowed steel to be brought in from
outside of Europe and which will pollute
the world twice as much I want to
comment in a way that we have to
understand that Europeans are ambitious
but for the next commission presidents a
main goal could be also to convince the
rest of the world to follow because we
cannot alone rescue the climate we have
to do it together with the other friends
and with the other partners on global
level and that's why the European
Commission the European Union must be
ambitious on the global stage to work
for a for a global development for an
engagement on global level to fight
together against climate change that is
what I want to do more so know from
where we'll start in Europe for goodness
sake answers and we go further to the
next topic next topic is one that might
come across slightly technically but I
think it's one that annoys many people
across the continent because it's a
symbol of unfairness and injustice
multinational corporations like Apple
Google or Nike are paying only marginal
taxes of often less than five percent
whereas we as ordinary citizens have to
pay between 20 and 40 percent our
question to the candidates is which
countries in the European Union are in
European tax havens
and how do you change their behavior to
make sure that Amazon pays as much taxes
as the bookseller
next door we start with Margaritaville
saga I have dealt with this firsthand so
you're very generous when you say that
some only pay 5% because someone pays
0.05 percent in some years as we saw it
in the Apple case so there is indeed
work to do
and what we have seen is now member
states they change taxation in Ireland
in the Netherlands in Luxembourg in
Belgium in Malta in Cyprus because
change is coming and we have changed the
legislation all over but we need two
things we need digital taxation because
a lot of these companies they are
escaping and most of the companies they
actually do pay their taxes this is
unfair and second we need to put a floor
under corporate taxation as such because
otherwise it will just be erased to the
bottom and we need companies to
contribute to societies where they do a
very good business and the cases so many
businesses do that already and we need
tax fairness very briefly the countries
you named are they tax havens but for me
it's axe Haven is the place where
everyone pays their taxes
Thank You mr. Sekulow you are the
optimistic as McGregor change is coming
I really hope so because this is a real
serious scandal that we're having right
now I mean you mentioned how little or
you mentioned how little taxes are being
paid by the big company so the strongest
memory so to say of society are running
away from their responsibilities and
that is costing us so much taxpayers
money in money that we don't have to
build schools to repair hospitals to
have a good educational healthcare
system so absolutely it is key that we
have tax justice this is part of social
justice so we need to indeed have a tax
for the digital big companies that can
easily evade taxation and we need to
have a minimum tax rate for companies
but what we also need is transparency
and this that needs to go for every
company and there we have already tried
to establish rules for the transparency
so that it's clear how many employees
does the company have in one country or
not because this is get attention
unfortunately the Liberals as well as
the Conservatives and the further
conservatives have voted for exemptions
to this transparency but I think there
should be no exemption to transparency
transparency goes for everyone thank you
very much Scott Keller and next in line
Vance timmermans your home country was
already mentioned is it the tech safe
well they've seen the writing on the
wall that this doesn't work anymore and
they're changing in it was about time
actually and I agree fully with Margita
when she says we need a corporate tax
minimum level in the whole of Europe I
would say let's put 18 percent as a
minimum level and then you have a fair
playing field and then countries can
decide to do more but they can no longer
decide to do less the thing is the
economy has changed so fundamentally we
are in the fourth Industrial Revolution
we have companies who have found ways
not to pay taxes at all Margot is right
these big companies don't pay taxes so
we should keep asking Alexa Amazon when
are you going to pay taxes thank you
very much and since we still have
training
seconds I would like to ask you if you
propose 18 percent corporate tax how do
you get Ireland agreeing on that I think
you know they are seeing that this is
hurting their economy in the long run
anyway you know these big warehouses
with nobody's working it's not in the
interest of any economy and so I think
we can convince everyone to follow that
road it's also an element of European
solidarity I'm even sure we can convince
my own country in this thank you thank
you for amendments yes that ideal what
do you think about transparency - well
first of all I have to say that there
will be probably very fundamental
difference amongst us because I believe
that states have the right to tax
businesses and European Union it's not a
state maybe some people wish European
Union to be a state and in that case I
understand that they are calling for
pan-european taxes I don't I believe
however that of course tax evasion
should be forbidden I believe that there
were good steps made forward there is an
exchange of informations for every
company whose turnover is bigger than
750 million of euros whether it pays
regularly taxes here on there so we can
easily identify those who do not pay
taxes and they can be taxed on a
national level I don't think that they
should be taxed on a pan-european level
and by the way I have to say that
Commission Festa
did a very good job on that on the
filing level playing field and on trying
to find a proper competitive environment
for European businesses thank you very
much
yandere do any coke way do you agree
that it's none of yours
Europe's business taxation or less but
it's not at all I think we've got to
recognize that in Europe we have got
whole areas where all the public
services have been done away with their
hospitals their schools public transport
frontline services have been taken away
and that they have to be in existence to
spend the tax money on even harmonizing
taxation our European level and getting
rid of the tax dumping which is which
Mars the landscape in Europe that's been
going on for years
those were plans but nothing has
materialized nothing's come of that so I
think we've attempt to go from fine
words to hard action on tax fraud 850
billion how many schools have mean how
much public services health care how
much could you get for 850 billion euros
and let's have the common decency to say
that there are quiz alors they are key
in lambaste thing the what's happening
and they should be protected and not
attacked thank you very much I was a
proud European man the European
Commission decided to to act against
Ireland margarita you and jean-claude
juncker to make clear that Apple has to
pay their fair contribution to our
European societies and that is what we
have to continue to use our economic
strengths a regulatory framework to make
clear that everybody has to pay and we
have to answer one question because we
share to fight against tax havens we
share that we need a digital taxation I
want to use the money of such a digital
taxation for the transforming process
for those who are the losers of the
digitalization so we share the common
idea but the big question is how to do
it and that's why we have to change in
some special fields in taxation from the
unanimous vote to the majority making
decision process that is that that it's
a test let me say whether we really
believe in this approach of a common
European engagement generally speaking I
believe in text competition but in
special fields like the digital taxation
we need a common European role
I just wondered at this stage of this
debate you all use your first riveted
counsel you have still won in the last
report or capture challenge other
candidates thank you for your answer and
by well-known technicians are certainly
hot topics we experienced that let's see
now how is it online yes we're back at
the social media hub and you've been
very very busy online using the hashtag
tell Europe and making your voice heard
so I want to thank you for that to give
you a better sense of what people are
saying online I would like to show you a
word cloud so climate and green they are
definitely the most popular keywords
being typed in and as you can see many
of you are also interested in interested
in getting to know the candidates
themselves and also knowing more about
the Commission and the elections which
are taking place from the 23rd to the
26th of May and another very popular
topic we have come across is gender
equality this person would like to know
how candidates are going to tackle the
gender pay cap and with the rise of
Euroskeptics and populist movements in
several European countries some of you
have also expressed some general
distrust towards the European Union here
is a tweet from Germany that I think
sums up what some people some of you
feel so they think that EU is they don't
people feel that it's not well enough
explained what the EU does and what it
is so keep sending in your comments and
questions with the hashtag tell Europe
and let's continue the debate online and
on the main stage
[Music]
thank you very much Anna Sina and we
turn to questions about our external
politics do you in a world dominated by
the US and by China more and more often
EU finds itself in an arm twisting
situation with those powers be it on the
Iran nuclear deal P it on north rim to
be it on free trade time and again US
president on a trumped veterans to
impose new tariffs on European goods so
this is a very broad topic but we like
to get a feeling of your stance in these
questions and our question to you as
candidates for the European Commission
in order to strike a deal with Donald
Trump which were probably one of your
tasks as a commission president and to
avoid damage for the European economy
are you willing to open European markets
to American agricultural products
including genetically modified ones as
Trump apparently demands first answer
from Sky canapes nope but I also think
we need to think a bit further and
really consider which role should the
European Union play in the world and I
think we would have an important role to
play and we need to consider which this
issue should be and we need to be united
in that my idea is that Europe should be
a force of peace and of human rights in
the world this is something where we can
really send out a strong signal and
we're already doing something right
we're the biggest donor for human rights
activists in the world but we're not
being coherent at the same time that
were the biggest human rights activist
owner we're also as European Union
member states sending weapons to
dictators sometimes the same that
oppressed them so we need to be coherent
we need to stop those weapons exports
into conflict area which also sends a
people on the move that then have to
flee we should stop being a haven for
dictators that put their money into
European banks for example we need to be
coherent and we need to care about human
rights wherever and whenever
[Applause]
gentleman how to be poor in front of
United States China well if we're united
we're stronger than that we are but if
we have leaders in Europe who are best
buddies with Vladimir Putin and go and
ask him for money who then go on an
audience to Donald Trump who wants to
weaken and break up the European Union
and you know how could we create unity
we have to understand what is at stake
for us as Europeans the first time in
living history that there is American
president who thinks it's in his
interest to have a weak and divided
Europe that's dangerous for us we can
divide it we will not be able to stand
up for our values in the world so we
need European unity and we need to
convince those political forces who
think that Putin is their best friend
all the way from Faraj to salvini to
Strucker all these people should
understand they are not acting in the
best interest of European citizens we
need to be united we need to stand firm
against Trump firm against Putin if we
do not do that they will dictate the
tone and the content of the music we
cannot allow that for the sake of our
citizens thank you very much France the
moments Manfred Weber can we just say no
one everything to trump evil pressures I
think not at all because the Americans
are still our friends American people
are our friends we have so much common
values in mind and we speak about the
freedom of press about they demand a
judiciary about the gender balance and
and the democracy so there is so much
which we have in common that's why I
don't fight against the American people
but what is happening in the White House
is not our approach of doing politics
that's why we have to be strict and
clear I would offer to the American
president let's do a deal on the
industrial goods so let's do so on trade
but only if we practice partnership if
he wants to force us Europe has to stand
up and has to act accordingly
that's why strength and unity of Europe
is necessary and again we need the
mechanism discussed so today we have
External Affairs the idea of unanimous
vote that's why Europe cannot act Europe
is not tricking us like this oil in the
Venezuelan case and that's why we have
to change towards a majority making
decision process only with such a new
mechanized
we can bring the whole strength of
Europe our value based alive for a
strong Europe a global stage you might
say what do you think about the
relations with the United States China
sponsored well I think that free trade
agreements often wake week in Europe
because we don't manage to get partners
to follow social and environmental
standards I think it's a shame when we
are the largest economy in the world if
you add together all of Europe's
countries we need to ensure that
European living standards are respected
free three trade agreements need to be
fair but they are being put in the hands
of private forms of justice that member
states fall victim to well I'll give you
an example
they only a question the Egyptian
minimum wage due to this private
arbitration that could simply overrule
States we need to be looking at the
rules in these kinds of treaties they
affect farmers industries the whole of
our populations in Europe that is how
that we will move forward your career
this is would you talk about
agricultural goods well first of all I
have to say that trade for us for Europe
is the major engine of economic growth
and I think that we should negotiate
with the United States because
transatlantic market is a huge
opportunity regardless who is at the
moment US president but it's not the
only market there are also other markets
and I was very happy as a vice chair of
the international trade committee that
we conducted for instance the free trade
agreement with Japan which created the
largest free trade area in the world
covering about 30% of the global GDP and
I think it's a good news I think we
should continue that and I think we
should focus in times where protection'
perfectionism is rising we should focus
on the goal to be a pioneer
for free trade and we should try to
conduct more free trade agreements
particularly with Asian countries
because this is what economic future of
the world lies thank you very much the
European Commissioner for for
competition you were comforted with his
other countries other power what do you
want to answer
well there's room for a much more
confident Europe as Nicolas sense this
is the biggest economic bloc in the
world with the biggest trading partner
with the preferred partner for 80
countries so a much more confident
Europe maybe also slightly more
hard-nosed because if we give access to
our markets we should have access to
other markets as well and when we ask
fair competition within Europe we should
also stand up for our businesses if they
are met with unfair competition outside
of Europe and that we need to push much
further than what we have done so far
and what we have retired is basically
you want me to stop talking I read your
body language like that thank you very
much no the point is to say that we have
retired sort of the old concept of free
trade and instead that we need to trade
in a value-based way because we have
interest when it comes to how
agriculture is done how animals are
treated how human rights play a role and
this is why the trade agreements with
Japan with Canada are such good news
because this is the way you can make
trade a positive input and that creates
millions of jobs thanks Margaret America
there was another rebuttal from Nick oak
we don't why we don't know who you want
challenged so on the suti Murmansk I I'd
like to challenge mr. Timmons because
mr. timmermans vice-president of the
European Commission
and I know that in his political family
at least in Wallonia there was a lot of
pushback against the setter treaty with
Paul man yet as the chairman for
Wallonia we still don't understand how
it can be that if you have a number of
different visions for the future through
this treaty you can accept that it is
negotiated beyond the states themselves
and in some kind of extrajudicial
European forum are we not sufficiently
Democratic and strong for us to debate
this with European citizens so that
democracy can really take its place good
sir cafe well I can tell you straight
away
that what Paul man yet said and what you
did together really influenced very
heavily the nature of the treaty that
really made a difference you talked
about arbitration but actually it's much
more public now than it was and that's
even been confirmed by the Court of
Justice in Luxembourg so your actions
and what Paul Meunier
did really helped us push ahead in that
direction which was much more public but
we haven't reached the end of the road
yet we've got a lot more to do but
already trade treaties are not just
things that are decided on by experts
but they're part of the public debate
effort vivir you want to use your or
less we don't get too much who you do
you want to challenge laughing yeah I
want to reflect on the trade issue
because today there is six million shops
in today's European Union depend on
trade we are trading continent the whole
economic strength is based on trade and
that's why I cannot understand why the
Left parties the Greens the Left Party
in the group and also the Socialists are
not stable on the question yes say yes
to use trade as an tool for making the
world a better place I would include and
all the trade agreements for the future
a paragraph to abolish child lay child
labor for example on global level let's
use the trade issue for making the world
a better place and left you cannot count
on this on the klephts
on this question of trade issues
you can surface the divorce city school
middle what cut well again that's fine
words but in practice social
environmental standards are going all
the way down because of those free trade
agreements we haven't got the machinery
we haven't got agencies at least that
which can stand up to the reduction of
living conditions for Europeans because
what you always say is the discourse
that doesn't allow Europeans to keep to
maintain their standard of living there
is a domestic consumption in Europe
which is substantial we are a big market
and millions of people who are working
for this internal economy and with your
international treaties the free trade
agreements they killed off that vitality
right in the heart of Europe because I
have been as well so I guess I'm getting
30 seconds on that as well
I do think that trade can play an
important role but we have to see it as
an instrument to get to a goal and not
as a goal in itself as it's currently
being always treated the more trade
agreements we have the merrier but we
need to watch out what they do and for
example if we just liberalize all
services then this is also not good for
the European economy if we just extract
raw materials from other countries this
is really not good for achieving a
global and multilateral system of
development so we really need to be
careful what trade is done how and for
what a
[Applause]
laughter Ghana who do you want to
challenge I'm so big I have a question
for mr. Ferber because to my great
surprise he said that he would support a
qualified majority vote for a foreign
policy and I still believe that foreign
policy is something which is driven by
national interest and by a very concept
of safe sovereignty and we see for
instance that in Libya Italy is
supporting general half-car while France
is supporting or its vice versa the one
country is supporting that warlord while
other country is supporting the
legitimate government in Tripoli so how
you can put this together and how you
can push one country by majority vote to
take completely different stance I don't
believe that it could work and it would
only deepen the divide amongst European
countries the question is not how to
manage it the pre questions the first
version is is it necessary and sorry
when you see exactly what is happening
in Libya when we see for example if this
development in Venezuela it took four
weeks of time to manage a common
European position against the communist
regime of Maduro four weeks of time due
to some individuals especially from
Greece and Italy and there is not the
Europe I dream about I dream of a Europe
which stands up for our values for
Tremec Rossi for rule of law for the
pride freedom which is the title of
Europe the freedom of our continent and
that is only possible if we come to
majority making decision process let's
make you look strong in these fashions
Wi-Fi sources thanks manfried river and
another rebuttal card or market a vest a
girl it's just a challenging I would
just like to discuss trade with scar
because I think there is also a climate
change dimension here for instance we
have a slovenian company who are very
famous in developing electrical planes
we have great european companies who
develop pumps wind turbines we have way
of organizing how to transform waste to
resources and all of those solutions are
exportable and you cannot export if you
cannot trade and you
trade as an instrument also when it
comes to bringing the world together
when it comes to using the best possible
solutions that we know already I agree
and yes we don't want to stop trade but
indeed it needs to take care for example
of the climate dimension in the current
trade agreement that is not in anywhere
we don't take into account for example
all the co2 emissions that we're
creating the Paris agreement is not
mentioned in any of the trade agreements
even human rights are totally just a
nice addition decoration but they're not
sanctionable so we need to put the Paris
agreement our climate targets that we
have all great and into the trade
agreements and that we have tried to do
we haven't so far gotten a majority in
the European Parliament was but we're
struggling for that because indeed it
the Paris agreements the climate goals
need to be everywhere also in the trade
agreement I think you all use your
little tongue only France even once you
have a last Republican so we are waiting
for for it
thank you for you all for your answers
so our final topic is the increasing
feeling of many people that the European
Union doesn't function anymore the
British but it to live the Union in
Hungary Viktor Orban wins election with
the second stop Brussels in Italy meteo
Savini
clearly won right same waves and you can
values out under sweet share with you
all of law procedures against Poland
Hungary with more to come and turnout
for the election has steadily declined
over the decades so our question to the
candidate is how do you explain the rise
of your Sept ISM and what is your share
of responsibility specular I would even
say that the problem is bigger the name
of the problem is bigger it's
nationalism it's dividing the European
Union there's forces that want to
destroy the European Union and that also
don't recognize the human rights of
other human beings that is the problem
that we face in Europe and there's a lot
of things that of course we need to do
about that can do about and I think one
very
important one is not to give them too
much space because it's not a law of
nature that they have to become bigger
and bigger and they are not if we look
around in different European countries
we all as Europeans take part in the
decision of how much space we give those
nationalist forces in the Europeans and
also as European parties we need to take
a decision are we collaborating with
those extremist forces
unfortunately the EPP we have that
situation in Austria where you have been
partnering with the effort we have the
whole or one issue that hasn't been
solved yet so I think it's really it's a
problem of whether whether we should
take distance whether we say we stand
strongly on the basis of European values
and human rights or we don't do it what
is your share of responsibility it'd be
it politics be it communications of the
actual acting European Commission's
let's be very clear people who used to
vote for my party and many parties here
are now voting for nationalist parties
sometimes even extremist parties that's
our fault
apparently we did not convince them to
stay with us apparently they believe in
these propositions they're now being
disappointed look at what the divisive
nosov brexit has done to United Kingdom
today the United Kingdom
looks like Game of Thrones on steroids
and that's because of this divisive
politics tomorrow's headline that's
there because of this divisive politics
so we have a collective responsibility
to offer propositions to our citizens
that will make them come back to the
European project will make them come
back to parties all the parties around
the table here who have constructive
propositions for the future this is the
only way forward and yes we are to blame
but we do have solutions and we talked
about these solutions tonight everybody
has this idea about this but we come
together on this idea of creating
European unity to solve the problems
that are facing us in the future
thank you very much because we didn't
exist
well the European Union existed but it's
being dismantled there is a risk that it
could be dismantled because we have seen
austerity policies of an unheard-of
violence used against southern European
countries that is why we shouldn't be
surprised to see people turning to
radical alternatives you should see what
the fascists are doing now within Italy
Hungary and elsewhere but we need to
make a choice either you choose the
markets and you are constantly
submissive to the law of the market or
you take a choice to support people the
people who live in Europe they are the
ones that we need to be addressing and
looking after but what have we been
doing we've been cutting their pensions
increasing the retirement age reducing
the public services giving them a
feeling of malaise of it is such that
people think that by withdrawing into
their nation-states they can be better
protected the responsibility is in your
hands you were the ones who pursued
these policies there are two left
rebuttal cards are with scapulae and
still mattes if I'm not mistaken but now
it's mantra paper soon my party the EPP
the Christian Democrats on this
continent are among the founding parties
of today's European Union and we see
that nationalism and echo is miss back
on this continent and what we have to do
over the 26 over of my for this year's
elections you have to find against Zeus
who wants to destroy our Europe you have
to defend our Europe no doubt about this
there are two elements important one
element is if you want to answer we have
to make Europe democratic in the brexit
case the main message of the practice
was I want to have my sovereignity back
people feel not that Europe is my Europe
and I want to change this this chamber
the European Parliament is a place that
the future of Europe must be decided we
need a democratic Europe for the future
the second point I want to mention we
need a mechanism to defend our values
they are challenged in the in the whole
European Union and that's why I'm
binding independent rule of law
mechanism for the future we can also use
the funds the
money of Europe to sanction Zeus who are
not ready to respect our fundamental
principles that is what I fight for as a
leader of reform is conservatives do you
want to defend Europe well I think that
the main problem is that people ordinary
people in European countries that do not
care about everyday politics somehow
tired from endless European integration
they feel that European units
interfering into their everyday lives
that it is threatening their traditional
ways of life their their social customs
and things like that
so yes I am very in favor in favor of
European integration and European Union
as well but as I said at the beginning I
want Europe that is doing less but
better slimmer scale back flexible
decentralized I don't think that more
Europe and more Europe and more Europe
is a universal response for each and
every problem like unfortunately EPP and
socialists that were running the
European business for the last 25 years
and I don't believe that I will be able
to come with some genuine change thank
you yes our ideal France moments I think
misses our ideal knows extremely well
that I have had a difference of opinion
with the Polish government whose party
as part of his group over the last three
years and people were saying oh don't do
this it would lead to pol exit people
will be disenchanted with you how does
mr. Cyril then explain that after three
years of very very tough conflicts with
this government the support for the
European Union in Poland is higher than
three years ago the Polish people attach
more importance to Europe than ever
before they want to be part of this
community of values give them that go
withhold that from them
thank you elements
from the polish people but I give you
another example from my own country
90% of Czech citizens of course want to
stay in the European Union so that means
that they somehow like the idea of
European integration while 75% of my
citizens do not want to adopt the euro
so there is a clear example that people
somehow like the European Union but do
not like everything which comes from the
European Union and we have to find the
right balance between the European level
and the national level which are very
much in favor of the European level
thank you very much and to
Margaritaville saga what makes people
turn away from the EU and do you see any
self-criticism I think there are many
reasons and if you want to change things
you need to change yourself first in the
way we talk we talk as very often as if
we were keeping a secret with all the
abbreviations we use last year we got
digital citizen's right that record GDP
are how can you expect anyone to
appreciate that we need to speak in a
different way we need to take off the
labels when people come to say this is
the problem and discuss it for real but
then of course we also have to apply to
ourselves to tell the truth and what is
now done to fight all the fake news and
all the junk news that we see out there
that is part of the solution to give
people real food for thought and invite
them back to real discussion about how
we unite our national democracies and
our European democracy to make it work
in everyday life thank you very much
Margaret America we are behind our
schedule so very quickly to anissina
what's going on in the social media
world well we have had thousands of
people engaging with us 5,000 people
watching on YouTube 28,000 on Facebook
7,000 on Twitter and in fact we have
been trending so far on Twitter in
Belgium Denmark Germany Ireland France
and Finland who vasami ketose and well
many of you have submitted questions on
specific topics a number of you have
also asked about broader issues so for
example from Italy we have a question
from a trip and European citizen who
asks why should I feel represented by
one of your national parties so back to
the main stage the candidates know how
one final opportunity to ask for your
supports so the six of you stage would
like to lead you up for the next job
three years so one minute to close
France immigrants I sorry I forty
seconds because we are scheduled
starting with
you have heard us today you've heard all
the differences I hope it helps you make
up your mind what you vote next week but
there's one thing I want to ask you
whatever you choose never become
indifferent choose let your voice be
heard if you don't vote somebody else
will take your voice it's like giving
your money to somebody else to decide
about your future vote in the European
elections let your heart speak vote for
the person or the party you believe will
fix Europe's problems best but volt
never let yourself become indifferent
if I would have the chance to ask my
grandfather the grandfather's generation
what do you think about today's Europe I
think they would answer the best Europe
be ever efsol and for the 26th of May
for these European elections is first of
all to defend it against the echo s
against the Nationalists were back in
Europe and I want to open the new
chapter I want to create optimism I want
to create future perspective for this
European Union for this great idea of a
united Europe and I say it again I want
to make it in a democratic way where you
have to say that you decide about the
composition of this chamber of the
European Parliament and V you give her
the advice what are the top subjects
what they have to deal with in the next
upcoming five years a democratic Europe
and a strong Europe two things first
it's important to show that we do change
and the most visible way to do is to
have a gender balance commission same
net men the same number of men as the
number of women that reflects our
societies and second the challenges
we've been discussing today they're
difficult we need each other to do it
but it take courage to overcome
ourselves and our differences to find
common solutions the power to change
comes from you voting is power go vote
in this election and inspire people
around you to go vote otherwise other
people will use it thank you
I would say that probably no one here at
this stage is happy with the state of
play of the European Union but each of
us has a different recipe what to do
with that my country joined the European
Union 15 years ago I'm coming from
rather different part of Europe maybe
with a different life experience and
maybe with different paradigm of
European integration and I have a
feeling that sometimes this is not
widely understood in other parts of
Europe that we are more sensitive to
questions like national sovereignty or
national identity so in order to work
together to live together to cooperate
together we have to find a way how to
sort it out and we have to find the
right balance between a European level
and national level as I said at the
beginning thank you scattered all over
Europe young people are taking to the
streets because they fear for their
future and they turn that fear and the
anger at the politicians not doing
anything they turn that fear and that
anger into action and we need to do the
same
we need to act because there is hope for
a better future and yes it can be done
but it does need change and it does need
courage and it does need a strong force
in the European Parliament that will
fight for climate protection for social
Europe and for democracy not just in
words but also in action and that is our
offer as grains to all Europeans
never know the law well we just seen the
European leaders they talk a lot but
they don't get to the heart of the
problems they're not dealing with
climate change global warming
precariousness they're not dealing with
tax evasion we want a Europe that
actually takes these problems and deals
with them by the horns in Spain we want
people to vote for Europe for feminism
in Italy people are voting we don't want
them to vote for fascism we want all
European citizens to be able to vote for
social states that actually give them a
decent life and we want Europe to
completely change course we're asking
then for a vote for the European left
which is the only party that can really
change direction that brings us to the
end of our debate I hope you spotted
somebody whom you think would make a
good president of the next European
Commission but anyhow please join us all
and showing your appreciation for all
the six candidates
[Applause]
let's see now what's happen online well
it was very lively you send us so many
first that we couldn't get to all of
them but we did know that some of you
asked for more coverage of all the
European elections and we also noted a
tree from a journalist from France and
fir that sums up what tonight's debate
has been all about a discussion that is
respectful and meaningful Thank You
anissina and to all of you here in the
parliament and of course at home don't
forget to take your chance to vote from
May 23rd to May 26 wherever depending on
wherever you live debate team for you
every we good night good night
Roberta when sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]